foreign
[Music]
it seems like you just had this [ __ ]
uncanny thing where like the bigger the
game the bigger the pressure the more
you showed up like just like you know I
mean not just in the Super Bowls but
like as the seasons as things became
more and more important as the pressure
got higher and higher it seems at least
from an outsider from a fan it's like
you became more and more dependable and
like you were that [ __ ] guy and I
guess I'm wondering like is
you got any you got any idea why that is
man and was that something were you like
that as a kid yeah
you know my dad was tough on me but the
person who was toughest on me the most
was myself
you know and and whether is I didn't
want to disappoint my dad or or I didn't
want to you know there was certain
whatever it was I was always a [ __ ]
tough critic and and and it goes back to
that preparation process like when you
practice hard and when you know you go
out and you don't have a good play on
seven on a seven and then you have team
and you get pissed off about that
and you think it's [ __ ] whatever but
then you have to think back and all
right I have to short memory you got to
go back on the track like it was like
life or death like I was like that for a
long time that when you get into the
certain situations that you practice and
you've practiced at a high level hard
all the time it was like clockwork you
know what I mean so I I would have to
say it would be just the straight
competition and the the
being toughest on myself you know what I
mean like
that's the one thing you know I you
could have the best game in your life
and you
I would always still think about that
one player I [ __ ] up yeah you know I
could have had a little bit you were
never satisfied that never satisfaction
kind of feeling that you have like you
know like everyone always talks about
that [ __ ] catch and Super Bowl
whatever against Atlanta yeah like I
don't think about that play I think
about fresh out of halftime I was a raw
raw guy and I dropped a [ __ ] third
down which I would have just I would
have kept running I would have still
been running if I would have caught the
ball okay you know that's what I think
about you think about the [ __ ] you
didn't are you in that office are you
that way in all facets if you're all
faceted to my life very hard on myself
you know and and it's something that you
have to learn you know how does that
manifest itself like how do you deal
with like when failure comes when
disappointment comes like does it come
you staying up at night thinking about
it does it like what what's the dialogue
in your head like what do you say to
yourself well you know everyone has a
everyone has that time where you sulk on
something
but then like I have my dad in the back
of my head like how the [ __ ] do you get
out of this you gotta work your way out
of it all right let's just get back to
fundamentals you have to have a short
memory whether it's good or bad I mean
because there's always going to be
another rep or there's going to be
another day there's going to be another
play in any facet of life there's always
something else you know the highest of
the highs there's gonna be something
else totally you know I mean so you know
just keeping that mentality that's what
I've always really had you know like
in the most adverse situations when I
was my absolute worst like in a low
point of my life
you finally hit that that spot where
you're like all right I'm over this
now let's let's get into problem solving
instead of all right we have the problem
we now we know we know the problem now
how we get the [ __ ] out of this problem
that's right you know whether it's you
know not doing a route right or doing
you know how do I make this better and
it just it comes back into competition
and I now you're competing with yourself
you know so that that's how I always get
out of [ __ ] I'm competing on just trying
to win the day you know I learned that
New England also you know you you're
either getting you're better you're
getting worse that's right there ain't
no [ __ ] standing still how was your
day did you get better today or did you
get worse you know so it's it sounds
simple but it's hard and that's what my
dad always told me life's hard but it's
simple but you know what you have to do
it's not always easy to do it you got to
have to sacrifice you're gonna have to
be disciplined there's gonna be think
but you know what you have to do
everyone knows what they have to do it's
just not always easy doing it you know
that kind of clarity it sounds like it's
like sort of the perfect marriage and
the way that you were growing up the way
that you grew up the things that you
accomplished and conquered along the way
and then to go on and build checks like
just just to go into that program does
that do you think that that system
doesn't work for some people like who
who like clearly there's people that
that has not worked out for what why why
do you think that would be do you think
there's like some people who like need
to kind of Lie to themselves or or or
can't stand that kind of honesty yeah
everyone's different you know and and
yeah I remember
you know some big name veterans that
roll through New England and you know a
little later in their career and they're
like what the [ __ ] is it I can't do this
what specifically can they not do wait
you you can't follow directions you know
it's it's simple there's a scheme
there's this this is what they want to
see this is what you should do uh it's
tough you have to work hard right the
day's not easy this isn't a [ __ ] walk
through that's right we're here to
[ __ ] compete it's gonna suck there's
no light at the end of the tunnel right
and if you do all that when when it
comes to nut cutting time it's like all
right let's go play you know a lot of
guys you know they just you know think
you could just lace up the cleats and go
because that's how it was where they
were at or in different areas of their
whole life they've been celebrated for
so long they just don't know how to
respond they don't know how to respond
yeah you know so it's it's it's
different you know some people need to
be loved up some people need to be
motherfucked some people everyone's
quite you know a little different so I I
it was like a match made in heaven when
I went to new review and it was tough
and what about I mean like uh New
England specifically and and Boston I
was telling the guys so I played
baseball in college and my my one of my
best friend is a guy named Sparky Davis
from from South Boston complete [ __ ]
nut we're probably the two biggest
Underachievers in NCAA history he just
like pitch on acid and and sometimes
he'd be like [ __ ] I mean he said he
was like a sidearm pitcher you know what
I mean yeah and like no matter what I
called he would like pitch what he
wanted you know what I mean and
sometimes he'd be [ __ ] great you know
I mean sometimes he'd be Ted like you
could bring him in for nothing and he'd
lose the game you know what I mean like
hit five batters in a row whatever but
like you know so I hit him up because I
lived in Boston for a long time I was
there when they won that first I guess
it was 2001 yeah 2000 was it 2001 or was
it two yeah and I'd never seen
you know I was living in South Paul I
was living with the him and his buddies
and uh like
is do you think that's the greatest
sports town in the country
I mean I I'm kind of biased yeah we
played there but yeah I mean it's it's
crazy it's unlike anything I've ever
seen
like they don't really have seasons they
have like there's no fall so it's like
baseball hockey season football season
or basketball season and it's a Pro
Sport Town that's right you know and
what separates them is all the pro
sports have had a lot of success in this
like chunk of period that I've been
there even before me you know what I
mean so they love their Sports they're
tough people they're [ __ ] Blue Collar
they're hard-working people they're it's
cold it's miserable in Boston and and
that's how a lot of those people are
they love going home after work putting
on the [ __ ] sport Channel watching
their game you know supporting their
team and that's that's the tough people
they are and that's kind of person I
grew up around that's what my you know
that's what we were that's what blue
collar people that worked hard that love
sports
um you know so it's a tough place but I
I didn't really
in New England when you're with with you
know coach Belichick and all those guys
yeah it's it's a tough place to play
when things aren't going well but they
also you know they they love their they
love their guys you know and
you don't really get to really
experience it as much as you you you
think you would because you're so
caught up in the game yeah and and the
coaching staff there at the time you
know they they they were so good at
making you ignore noise and putting so
much on your plate where you had you
couldn't think about anything else you
know you were thinking about getting
your body right you were thinking about
you know what the game plan the install
was what's the third down plan today
what's the red area for tomorrow like
all these things you were thinking about
uh you know so they did a great job of
occupying your mind uh
where you didn't get to see necessarily
all the great things and the shitty
things of of what goes on and you know I
just know for me you know playing
playing High School sports it was so it
was so [ __ ] vital right it was like
these are the guys I grew up with we
hated the people we were playing as my
buddy coaches at um modern day and his
son just graduated from there went on
got a scholarship to play a cow and he
was saying he grew up in Arkansas and he
was saying how like you know back in the
day when you play in high school sports
like you [ __ ] hated your Rivals I
mean to this day when I'm in DC like I
don't care who you are I don't care what
I'm doing if you want a picture with me
or an autograph like I'm stopping but if
you're wearing a [ __ ] Saint Albans
shirt dude I will not take a picture
like you're taking that [ __ ] shirt
off I won't do it like those are the
only people really on Earth to this day
I gotta say I hate I guess like once you
get into college
at least you know me and my like D3 life
or whatever it's like I don't give a
[ __ ] about Rensselaer Polytechnic
incident like I don't really you know
it's it becomes more of like a business
and I imagine in the pros you know it's
it's there's such a huge fan base but I
guess I I guess my question is did you
when you're playing on these legendary
teams and you're like
I mean I would imagine even even more so
than if you were a Yankee in the Heyday
like that team like you did you love
that city did you not want to let that
City down I mean what was your
relationship to the people of that City
I understand you were sort of yeah it
was it was awesome man they embraced me
I was a California kid went out there
and and they
they embraced me and my family and
you know when you when you play in
Boston
you know you you see the you know the
Red Sox well they won a World Series
when I was there and then the Celtics
won a championship and the Bruins won in
2011. there becomes like a competition
thing where like all right these guys
did it no we gotta go [ __ ] do it
because you know you know it becomes
like that because
you know there's a standard
and you know I understand when what you
said when you go to college either the
Rivalry you know but like I tell you
right now I [ __ ] hate the New York
Jets yeah
you know what I mean and and that's just
how it was because you know Boston New
York is is pretty gnarly big time you
know people get up for it you know Iris
the Giants I can respect a little bit
about you know what the Giants yeah they
had they held us they got us twice in
the Super Bowl but the Jets man it was
it's it was a dog fight every time you
played a New York team yeah and you knew
that yeah you know you could feel the
buzz around the city you could feel the
buzz in Foxboro yeah you know you could
hear certain things what people were
saying even though you were trying to
ignore [ __ ] uh especially when social
started getting bigger and bigger so you
know it was it was awesome to play for
you know New England and and Boston I
mean I I grew up in Boston pretty much
as an adult yeah I got there at 22.
right I left at 34. you know mean so
like I I know [ __ ] Cape Cod better
than I know Lake Tahoe I know Boston
better than I know San Francisco where I
grew up like you know you become part of
the city you go to the games you support
you know the Red Sox I became friends
with like pedroy and Paul Pierce and you
know Tuka and Sagan all these guys like
we'd all hang out and stuff and there's
a camaraderie that you definitely feel
in that City because there is no college
teams people out there they always like
pros that's right and that's cool when
you're a pro guy yeah yeah yeah I mean
every one of these guys that I reach out
to like the umbros and the grocery you
know all the only question they have was
just like is he coming back like come
back we just went like that's all I'm
like [ __ ] like really that's all good
and one of them was like you know my my
dad's one was was like you know my dad's
Jewish and my mom's not and I'm
wondering if if he considers himself the
most handsome half Jewish athlete and he
was like because I think I am I'm like
dude they're [ __ ] worthless bro yeah
they're [ __ ] worthy yeah I mean I am
I come I don't know I I'm probably not
going to come back we'll see yeah I
heard there's 100 million in the cap
next year for the Patriots we'll see how
that paycheck's looking let's go and you
know I heard there's a couple rumors
that Brady might be going over there you
know and might be going back that's what
they were saying it's coming back you
never know yeah but I'm content right
now with my my I love being a dad I love
the the work that I'm doing right now
I'm on inside the NFL I've got a podcast
as well games with names uh you know so
it's it's a transition and I'm I'm
hitting those
competitive
uh needs through different stuff now you
know it's not quite football it never
will be football it never will be you
know sitting in a locker room with the
boys but you know I get to go and hang
out with you know Phil Sims Ray Lewis
that's right Brandon Marshall
Michael Irvin and we get to talk Paul so
you get that kind of locker room sense
with that but you know it's tough man I
left a lot I left it all on the field
bro like I did it was uh you know when
you can't when you can't go out and do
fundamental things and things that
you've done your whole life
like at the click of your hand anymore
and you have to like get up for it and
it becomes work it's not you know not
what it was it's tough you know and it
hurts it hurts you as an athlete when
you throw on the film and you're
watching a practice and you're like man
that ain't me what the [ __ ] is that like
that I respect the game too much so yeah
yeah you know my body's feeling good but
yeah that's good it's tough yeah yeah
and what do you think like you know I I
was I was thinking about this too the
the other day you know it's like there's
something I feel like with you man that
that uh so many people kind of uh they
see themselves in you I think I think
like this again this whole like idea of
an underdog and whether you ask for it
or not I think like when we look at
people
we look at athletes like you know you
look at guys like LeBron James or Shaq
or [ __ ] you know Ray Lewis or
whatever you look at them and you're
like wow that's this like [ __ ]
physical specimen like they're almost a
different you know it's just like a
different species of but like it's it's
but but when you think about it's like
you're you're really the anomaly like
you're real like guys your size like
that's really what's [ __ ] absolutely
extraordinary and and and
um and and
do you do you feel that do you feel that
like people people sort of um
have that uh root for you in that way
and sort of see themselves in you like
did you that that that that Underdog
thing like did you did you feel the
weight of that are you just trying to do
your thing I was trying to do my thing
but you definitely feel that you know
yeah
you know you would feel the good with it
you know people like hey man and then
you would feel sometimes people you know
try to size you up you know you go
somewhere and they're like oh this guy
can do what I could [ __ ] do yeah
every time I walk in a boxing gym like I
think I could whoop The Punisher exactly
that pardon me is like all right [ __ ]
you you know what I mean so you know it
goes both ways but you know
I never really worried about that you
know I I I I I I love that if you can
help someone and Inspire someone [ __ ]
it's awesome because ultimately you know
that's what carries on and you know
you're you're gonna be done doing
something but if you can give knowledge
or you can give a story or some
inspiration to a kid that like was my
age with I needed when I saw you know
Jerry Rice or or when I when I saw you
know Doug Flutie I was a fan of Doug
Flutie undersized quarterback like
that's the cool thing about this whole
thing you know what I mean and
especially now that you have your kid
now you're you're really worried about
what your kid yeah yeah you know it's
everything you know every it's awesome
when people you know it's awesome that
people support and and relate to you
um but you know it I you're just living
bro that's right yeah I mean yeah
everyone's got a story
you know so
[Music]